hi in this module i'm going to be
talking about the generalization of
machine learning algorithm
so recall that a machine learning
framework has three design decisions the
first is the hypothesis class which
could be linear predictors or neural
networks the second design decision is a
loss function which in the case of
regression is could be word loss
it's of classification it could be the
hinge or logistic loss if you take the
loss and you average them you get the
training loss which is our training
objective that we've so far been
optimizing
and finally we have the optimization
algorithm which is either gradient
descent or stochastic
all good so far
now let's take a step back and be a
little more critical
is this
the training loss in particular a good
objective
optimizing
so here is a little cartoon example
that does really well on training laws
here it goes it's called rote learning
so the role learning algorithm is just
going to store all the training examples
and then it's going to return this
predictor and this predictor takes
an input x and it's going to search for
x in the training set and they can find
it then it's going to return the
corresponding y
and otherwise it just gives up some seg
follows our questions
okay so this
learning algorithm minimizes the
objective
perfectly it gets zero training loss
but
you can kind of tell that it's a bad
idea but it because it doesn't get
anything else right
so this was an example of extreme
overfitting here are some examples of
less extreme overfitting in pictures
so here's an example from
classification um you can see that the
green decision boundary here tries
really hard to separate the blue and the
red points and does so successfully
getting zero trigger
but you can kind of intuitively sense
that it's overfitting
and perhaps this black decision boundary
would be better
in case of regression this
red curve gets zero training loss by
going through all the training points
but you can see that it's overfitting
and instead maybe you should be
capturing the broader trend using simple
line
so in general if you try to overly
optimize the training loss then you risk
over fitting the noise in the
so then what is the true objective if it
isn't the training
well to answer that question let's take
a step back and think what are we trying
to do machine learning is just a means
and the end is a predictor that you're
going to launch into the world and make
predictions on real people
and this just happens to be trained from
a learning algorithm
so how good is this predictor in
the world
well
the answer is
it's the goal that how good it is
depends on how well it's able to
predict on unseen future examples so our
true learning objective should be to
minimize the error on unseen future
examples sounds great
only one small problem is that we don't
have access to the future and in
particular if we don't see the examples
how can we do anything about them
so
often we settle for the next best thing
which is
get a test set
and the test set is just a set of
examples that you didn't use for
training so it is a surrogate for
the unseen future examples
so i make this distinction
uh because i want to stress the fact
that when you deploy a machine learning
algorithm into a predictor into the
world
it might encounter all sorts of you know
crazy things um and
what you
do in the
training and in the lab is all you have
is a test set so
the what you're trying to do is trying
to have the test set be as close and as
representative of what you actually get
in the real world as possible
so
now we have an intuitive feeling for
overfitting is can we make this a little
bit more precise in particular when does
a learning algorithm generalize from the
training set
to the test set because that's kind of
what we've settled for
so
there is a way to make this
mathematically rigorous but i just want
to give you the the framing of how to
think about generalization
so the starting point is f star
this is the predictor
that is the ideal thing it predicts
everything as correctly as you can
before
um this lives in the family of all
predictors
of course we can't get to f star
so what do we do well we do two things
we first
define a hypothesis class script f
and
then
we are going to
have a learning algorithm that
finds a particular predictor within this
hypothesis class
so another predictor i'm going to
talk about is g
this is also a kind of a thing that you
can't get a hold of it's the best
predictor that you can find in the
hypothesis class
so now
this this
we're interested in the difference
between the error
of the thing you have
and the thing that you wish you had okay
so mathematically that's written as
error of the learn predictor minus the
error of f star id
and this error can be decomposed into
two parts
the first part is the approximation
error
approximation error is the difference
between g and f star
mathematically that's the difference
between the error of
uh
that's approximation error is the
difference between
the error of g minus the error of f star
this measures how good your hypothesis
class is
the second
error is the estimation error
which is the gap between
f hat and g
this measures how good is the learn
predictor relative to the potential of
the hypothesis class error of f hat
minus the error of g
and you can verify this identity because
we're doing just subtracting error of g
and adding error of g
so this right hand side is equal to this
left-hand side
this trivial identity highlights these
two quantities approximation error and
estimation error and gives us a language
to talk about the trade-offs and
generalization
so let's get some more intuition about
how approximation and estimation error
behave as you increase the size of the
hypothesis class
so when
the hypothesis class grows
the approximation error will decrease
this is because
approximation error is
measuring how good g is and the g is the
best thing in the class and if you're
adding more things the best thing is
just going to
get better
so in other words you're taking a min
over a larger set bound to decree
where you're
optimizing
the second thing that happens is that
the estimation error increases
when you the hypothesis class grows
and this is because
it's harder to estimate something
more complex there's just more functions
that the learning algorithm has to
figure out which one's the correct one
given the limited data
so there are ways uh to make this more
precise using the tools from statistical
learning theory but i'll just leave it
as an intro for now
so given these tradeoffs
what are the ways that we can use to
control the hypothesis class size
so we're going to focus our attention to
linear predictor so remember in linear
predictors the
the each predictor has a particular
weight vector
so effectively the number of way the
size of the set of weight vectors
determines the size of the hypothesis
class
so one thing you can do
is to reduce the dimensionality
of the set of possible wave vectors
so pictorially this looks like this so
imagine you have three features
so the set of weight vectors or this
three dimension of each weight vector is
just a
ball
and
if you remove one feature then you end
up with a two-dimensional
uh ball
um equivalently this is saying one of
the features has to have zero weight
which you can think about as a
restriction on a set of values that w
so how do you control the dimensionality
of practice
the process is called feature selection
or feature template selection
you can do this manually by adding
feature templates seeing if they help
and removing them if they don't and
you're trying to kind of manually figure
out which what is a small set of
features that actually gets you good
accuracy
dude there's also ways to do this more
automatically you can do forward
selection boosting more l1
regularization this is beyond the scope
of the class
but there are ways to make this more
less manual
one thing i want to stress is that
controlling the dimensionality
dimensionality is this number of
features and that's the key quantity
that matters not the number of feature
templates
and also not the complexity of each
individual feature so imagine you write
a thousand lines to compute one feature
well it's still a very simple uh
hypothesis class because it's just one
feature so in so far as generalization
is concerned
so the second strategy
is controlling the norm or the length of
this wave
so we can reduce the norm of or the
length
visually this looks like if you have a
set of weight vectors which are bounded
in length
um you can shrink the length and that re
results in a smaller
circle which is clearly a smaller number
of weight vectors
and so this is probably the most common
way
to
um
control the norm
so
there are
two ways to do this one is
uh by regularization so remember the
objective which we didn't like was
minimizing the training loss
of w because that can lead for fitting
so
you one way to recognize is you add a
penalty term
lambda over 2 times the norm of w
squared
okay so w is a positive number
which controls the strength of this
penalty
and what this penalty does is it says
let's try to
minimize the training loss but
we also want to keep the norm small
because we're taking a min over the sum
here
so if we look at what gradient descent
does to this objective we can interpret
it as follows so gradient descent
remember initializes weights iterates
over t epochs
and performs an update so the update is
w minus eta the step size times
this
gradient of the training loss
and now we take the gradient of this
penalty which is just lambda times w
so
remember we're subtracting eta so if w
is um
let's say uh 10 comma 10
then what we're going to do is we're
going to subtract that vector and move
the weights closer uh to zero
by a amount that depends on
so another way to control the norm is by
early stopping so early stopping is a is
really easy
to explain so here it is um you run
gradient descent you initialize w and
you repeat a number of epochs and uh you
perform the update and the only thing is
that you're just going to reduce the
number of epochs you go for
that's it
so
this seems like a hack um there is you
can develop some theory about it but the
intuition is that when you start the
weights at zero that's the smallest norm
and when you update the weights over a
number of iterations the norm of w is
actually going to grow it's not obvious
that this always happens but empirically
this true generally
so by stopping a gradient descent early
you're saying don't let the norm of w
get too big
so the lesson here is you're trying to
minimize the training error but you're
not trying too hard because you're just
going to call it quits after a while
okay so let's summarize now
so we started by saying
the training loss
is not the true objective
the real objective is
minimizing the loss on
unseen future examples
unfortunately we don't have access to
that so we're going to settle for the
loss on some test data which serves as a
surrogate to the unseen examples
then we studied approximation and
estimation error as a way to
understand generalization and it's
always going to be a balancing act
between fitting the training error and
not
letting your hypothesis class grow too
big
and the mantra to end with is perhaps
just keep it simple
so right now we've introduced a bunch of
knobs for comparing the size of the
hypothesis class
next we'll see how to actually turn